- All right, before we wrap up the hour,
I wanna share one last story
I hope will make you smile.
This is What I'm Liking.
(bright upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
As we approach Father's Day,
I wanna tell you about a mama in Detroit
who's making sure the whole world knows
just how incredible her man
is as a husband and dad.
So check out this very
sweet TikTok she posted
- [Eden] Ever since having our
baby, my husband makes sure
that I get eight hours to sleep every day,
which means he usually gets about four.
At first I felt guilty,
but he insisted and
explained it to me like this.
There are so many burdens
that you carry that I cannot.
All the burdens of
pregnancy, birth, recovery,
breastfeeding, lack of
sleep and late nights
with the baby is the only
burden I can take from you.
So why in the world would I not?
(gentle guitar music)
(audience applauds)
- That is incredible.
We have this couple
on the line right now watching
on WXYZ Channel 7.
Hi, Eden.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Jonathan.
Look at your beautiful kiddos.
Oh, my gosh.
So, Jonathan, way to step up
and just make all dads look so bad.
Why is this so important to you?
- Yeah, we really just learned so much
after having our first child
Zion here who is almost two.
And one of the things we
learned is that there's just
a lot of things that
parents don't talk about.
- And one of those things-
(Zion cooing)
- Bye, bye, bye, bye.
- One of those things is just
that people don't really talk
about how difficult the recovery can be
for the mom after having a baby.
And they're going through that recovery
while also having to
take care of the baby.
So after having our
second child here, Ezra,
we just really wanted to
improve the situation.
So I really focused on making
sure she got enough sleep
the whole night since
that is this thing I was able to help with
while she was recovering.
- That is so cool, man.
Eden, what did that feel
like to just be supported?
- I mean, so after I had
Zion, our first child,
I got really bad postpartum depression,
and I think a lot of that had
to do with the lack of sleep.
And so, this time around
Jonathan was really determined
to make sure that my recovery
went as smoothly as possible,
which for me meant getting more sleep.
So, yeah, and it just really showed me
how much he loved me and cares for me.
- Yeah, and loves your kiddos.
It's such a beautiful, beautiful thing.
I am liking your post right now.
(audience applauds)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen makers of G2,
the go-to pin of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
wanna honor ultimate
overachievers just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- Thank you guys so much.
(audience applauds)
Nothing but good health,
and God bless you and your little kiddos.
(audience applauds)